hey everyone welcome to new rockstars
news hello we are here at vid oh we are
so invited to bring our weekly panel
discussion here with you in person we're
gonna get to meet you we're gonna hear
your questions and we will have no
excuse if we don't have an answer
because we can't run away or edit out of
it
guys in today's episode we're gonna be
talking about this upcoming merger with
Disney and Fox and how the x-men can be
brought into the MCU what are the right
in the wrong ways to do it we're gonna
be talking about that there's so much we
got to talk about and as I said we're
here in Anaheim Convention Center at
VidCon I haven't been come on filmora
worth so nice to host our show whoo
thank you so much going lash it's great
it's a video editing app really easy to
use it's we're potentially gonna start
using ourselves because it's got great
music on it it's got titles that you can
like really easily make look like action
movie titles and it's like really nice
to us right now but letting us take over
their booth check that out at filmora
wondershare calm yeah they'll also be a
link in the description to check it out
yeah and we'll be talking more about
four more throughout this episode before
we do let's introduce ourselves I'm Erik
Bosse joining me here my best friend
hey Sam bachelor thank you
I'm Phillip Melina
[Applause]
[Music]
and hey and Zack Taylor special guest hi
those of you gathered around may have
noticed Sam and the rest of us throwing
out these wristbands he say spared by
Thanos so we're giving this out
throughout the weekend if you happen to
survive the snap I'm gonna call out as
soon as we said that they say spared by
Thanos a lot of people started reaching
out for them
this means you survive the snap so come
get a wristband if you want one yeah
start with our top story the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is version of the
x-men we have learned that its merger
between Disney and Fox is afoot because
Disney outfit Comcast bid of whatever it
was before it's not a million three
billion dollars a number
I have no fathom understanding of how
much money that is but it means that
this prospect of the x-men joining the
MCU is getting closer and closer and
let's talk about the best way for Marvel
to do this because I feel like there's
now a ton of amazing heroes and villains
who are gonna be entering this Cinematic
Universe and yeah there's a lot of
opportunity but there's a lot of
opportunity to get things wrong so you
know we've seen Marvel and Kevin Feige
they've been hugely successful with the
Avengers right the way they've rolled
out Black Panther the guardians of the
galaxy Doctor Strange but in the early
years it was kind of a product of
necessity they had sold off all their
big properties of spider-man and the
x-men Fantastic Four so they kind of had
to go with them and yeah the gamble paid
off they're huge but now they have to
everyone coming back under one roof is
there a way that they can screw this up
is there a way to get it wrong that's
the main topic today how yeah all the
ways yeah man
Sam to start us out I got you right so
in you guys correct me if I'm wrong but
we're at a convention and I'm a little
dehydrated so bear with me I remember in
the ultimate comics they introduced that
the mutant gene was like an egg was
created by accident by the US government
and that's like how they started getting
activated was because he got in the
water system and that's how people
became mutants I think that'd be a
really easy way to kind of like like
wherever they'd been it's like well
actually they haven't been around
like that very they're a very new idea
to the world so you can move forward
with that it makes it easier kind of
like spider-man how long's you've been
around six months easy peasy lemon
squeezy no but what about the spider by
seam by seam by eye we don't talk about
bio they said it five times fast in the
trailer by sim bio no sounds like
garbage
I smell I smell garbage
well I think the big question is should
they completely reboot the x-men movies
that we've seen before with completely
new actors or should they bring McAvoy
Jennifer Lawrence x-men we've had so
many iterations already that we went
back in time and we've got younger
versions of all of them and then we went
back forward in time and then we've
they're still there and then somehow
Oscar Isaac had his worst performance
we've ever seen it's still happening
though x-men is like to have a new
iteration where we haven't even seen
Dark Phoenix yet so your role Star Wars
is doing it they're collecting their
thoughts and they're taking some
much-needed time to map out a plan
I think the Russo brothers do such a
good job storyboarding and having it all
fit together but to put the x-men in on
that sit down but hey to be fair there
were two different iterations and
universes for spider-man and then you
got the MCU want to news the best one
yeah I feel like the fact that they have
rebooted it so many times makes it
easier to reboot it again I don't know I
wouldn't mind Realty issues fair but I
write real quick I'm not just gonna jump
in real quick so the big question seems
to be personal with your name is he all
right do you start over with the x-men
if now the x-men get to join the MCU do
you bring in the existing x-men or do
you start over with brand-new versions
of them I understand mods point but I
would prefer if they just start over I
don't know I just think bringing even
though if a merger happens I don't it's
just that they seem like two separate
worlds to me I realize they're all the
same like property but that's like
separate we've already done that I don't
want to have those characters again in
that reiteration if we're gonna start
fresh and bring
to the MCU I'd rather we just new actors
new storylines whatever don't know like
a great point is he thinks to all those
other actors should be fired and never
be allowed to work again what about you
what do you think just start over new
start over with something fresh with new
web with new storylines - because it's a
new era and it's a new sort of era for
filmmaking and for for the universe as
well yeah I think one really fun way to
introduce all these characters in the
poll with it would be with a really good
villain because not only do you get the
heroes you get characters like dr. doom
who can come in and be part of this just
introduce a doctor to movie right away
and then everyone on the other side
shows up to to fight them sorry now went
right into someone's face I'm sorry I do
think that better than ever we are
having villains that I respect and I
want to thank you you can get behind but
I like I like where we're going with the
villains side of things I think it's a
bit of a saturation it takes like seven
heroes to take down one villain these
days yeah so yeah I like that I've lost
my train of thought I put my name in the
running for the new Professor X I'll
shave for it let me know in the comments
or actually can I get a cheer for that
since we're live just oh yeah this is
the comments section by the way uh-huh
real quick at the count of three first
person to say first three two one oh he
was so first but it wasn't at the count
of three that means you didn't actually
watch the video you just went and wrote
first you get a bracelet for it a
wristband oh damn good joke YouTube
specific oh my god
there are like winds up there that are
controlling these throws you're right
blame it on the wind alright so yeah
definitely for those of you watching at
home weighing in the comments below what
you want to see but I couldn't move on
to the trivia question because that's
something we do yay so you guys all
ready to play along with a trivia
question MCU trivia question I think
yeah all right here we go
an early draft of the Iron Man script in
2008 established Tony Stark as the
designer of the tech of a Marvel super
villain but the line had to be cut
because the rights to the villain were
owned by another movie studio who was
that super villain so yeah as always
we'll reveal the answer to the question
at the end of the episode and the winner
will get two goodbyes or loser will have
to do something different this time
special punt live punishment edition
pain Olympics don't look that up well we
are going to move on to an update that
came out this week there's now an online
campaign called pre-baked the last Jedi
that's asking people to pledge money for
a team of producers to remake the movie
and save Star Wars and that's the thing
we got some some kind of tongue-in-cheek
responses from people who worked on the
film including director Rian Johnson who
said please please please please please
support it PC studio you don't even give
money it's not like a Kickstarter
GoFundMe you just pledge money the way
you would for like a kid's jog-a-thon
and at school and another filmmakers and
actors are weighing in they're like oh
they're giving pitches on how you should
we make it like one pitch said that like
they just want Luke Skywalker to milk
that sea cow for four hours so yeah
as well he did sucio de really are kind
of personally upset by it and again Rian
Johnson says his responses are always so
fun he leans into the joke or he just
mocks himself as well and I love that
attitude because he spends a lot of time
on Twitter yeah it would be awful if
they ostracize him and got rid of him
because he's he's funny in timelines and
feets hi yeah Rian Johnson yeah idea is
he over there spying big with the eleven
year old girls yeah Rian Johnson's going
by everybody right okay
they got quieter not humblebrag oh you
got thank you
I got weirdly really angry about this
like I you get angry about like like
like other things on Twitter but like
the more I read this I'm just like it's
so delusional it's so like not in touch
they're like we're gonna wait and sit
down we're going to sit down with Disney
what and they're gonna get permission to
do this like put it to what level you're
getting the actors back where you can do
about Carrie Fisher they said they're
gonna honor how you're gonna edit her
into the movie with like green screen
from other films the best way to honor
someone is to mimic them with bad CGI
it's like it's just it's it's it's
pathetic it's like pathetic and it's
delusional and I just wish that money
was used for literally anything else
happening in the space right now where
people feel like they have actual
ownership over these franchises and the
things that they love that they own it
and if they don't like it and feel
disrespected by it they have the right
to change it and
like you know what these franchises have
been going on longer than we've been
alive on the earth and if it's going to
evolve and change that's a natural thing
and if you don't like it you don't have
to keep liking it nothing says that you
have to continue to be a fan forever and
maybe if you got that Star Wars tattoo
get it lays it off whatever I just I
think it's what I thought I bought I
bought five Yoda waffle makers and that
means I have a ownership of his entire
France you have a seat on the board I
love when they were like we'll talk to
you guys so you were you were in on this
together it's like that's not how movies
are made if you had perfect example
snakes on a plane everyone's favorite
movie right that was made by a bunch of
people it turned out amazing
yeah why get angry yeah Eric wrote
stinks on a plane
[Laughter]
you wrote that phrase again and again on
his walls what's up next another quick
shot up for those of you who have joined
us a big thanks to Phil Mora for hosting
today's episodes they've been so great
it's an easy-to-use editing app and
software that gives you easy to use
templates and music options so
definitely check it out they're they're
great to use the URL Mora dot
wondershare dot-com that's all we are
special unicorns okay let's move on to
another topic that's come up as we
mentioned before we're handing out these
awesome wristbands so that we can be
proud that we have been spared by thanos
and as we've been doing this we have
started to think more about this idea of
who else survived the snap right and all
those lucky survivors and how they could
step up to take over the mantle if
Marvel needed them to I mean when I saw
the end of the movie and half the
characters who I loved started to fade
away at first there was this shock and
confusion like Marvel has already
announced another spider-man movie you
know they're gonna do another Black
Panthers
audience so how are they gonna do this
and it first like okay they'll find a
way to reverse it but do they need to
because let's face it Marvel has done an
amazing job filling out these characters
worlds with amazing supporting
characters who we love in some cases
even more than the original mantle hero
so let's talk about characters like
Sheree in black panther in Baku med from
spider-man Wong from Doctor Strange and
rock n FeO who are left over from the
Guardians could you see any movie where
these characters take over the role
maybe hey could you see any movie with
any of these characters but surely a
Sheree Black Panther mystery yeah like
four times
these smart has four times the
intelligence of Tony Stark yeah and it
doesn't hurt that she had materials that
were elevated and had the capabilities
beyond what Tony Stark had you know but
Sheree is 16 and has already created
more stuff than Tony Stark has even had
a tinkerer out and he's alive like 45 so
yeah I think sure he's gonna save the
universe I'm sure even so I think mod
probably just cooked the best answer by
the way but I'm gonna visit the gang
over here I'm just gonna ask real quick
who do you guys think deserves their own
movie somebody who survived the snap
again get your wristbands I'll throw one
at you by only someone who survived the
snap who should get their own movie and
maybe take over their franchise happy
hogan road trip happy hogan road trip
did you just pitch a whole three movie
franchise turned jon favreau going on a
road trip in the style of like Vegas
vacation a jungle book anything that
gets me watching Jon Favreau making and
eating more cubanos I'm down for it
what's your name Brian thanks Brian
all right buddy go
maybe's was it back-to-back in a row it
was it was only third 12 or 13 I would
have done 19 I wanted all 19 you used to
be like a nine-year-old and then this
happened to Congrats so you look great
do you have any ideas anybody should
take over Marvel movies get their own
movie cable cables are really solid
answer josh brolin taking over yeah just
cause like I really I like double to a
lots but I will really like to see em
full movie about cable story on this
side about what's going on before he
went to decide to go into the future
well the president they weren't Deadpool
is now just to see how the full story of
how the war became of it and stuff like
that just because that might be a better
answer they said mod previously had the
best answer but cable getting his own
movie also maybe partially in the future
oh that does sound really really good
mod has a retort anybody else got a last
pitch for me for someone who deserves
their own Marvel movie you got one yeah
sorry sorry I hit you in the face
earlier with the wristband right okay so
you just called out one of the biggest
like plot holes right Pepper Potts
should be able to use her extremists and
help people instead she founded goop
comm and she helps in a different way
actually but I like that just Pepper
Potts are really like like shouldn't
Tony also have I don't know alright but
it sounds like we're getting a lot of
the Iron Man periphery characters yeah
yeah
even though Iron Man is still around and
they're gonna take over the movie for
him what do you guys think but they
pitched a war machine movie a while back
they didn't get made and that would be
really cool as well because he's got all
the cool weapons to pop out also sure he
as black panther is like they always a
lot of people are like she should be
Iron Man because tech and everything but
she has a black panther cost
that she wears to have those like sound
gauntlet things that are real cool I
would love to see that we're introduced
Miles Morales in the MCU like they
hinted at them in the homecoming house
Morales fans let's see like I'm looking
super looking forward into the
spider-verse and maybe judging off of
the success from that if it blows up
let's like introduce am in the
live-action world it'd be great
there was actually will want Miles
Morales his origins because Peter Parker
spoilers dies so since he's kind of big
they didn't hear me I'm spider-man on
the floor right now crying the guy
dressed as spider-man but no that's a
since he's kind of it's worth what burb
are you trying to illustrate he
evaporated he dusted he dusted yeah it
could be like a little MCU adaptation of
that origin so maybe this is when is
time to shine it'd be great yeah swings
into action yeah dream casting really
quick on Miles Morales moonlight yeah
he's great he's a black panther at the
end it's great he's good
well let us know for everyone watching
at home what version of these new movies
that you would want to see in this kind
of fan fiction reality where maybe these
characters stay dust it away it probably
won't happen but it could and there's a
way forward if that happens but for now
let's move on to another update from
this week for those of you who are still
watching The Walking Dead we actually
heard some way forward in the future
they don't want to admit we were
committed that I'm committed in the pot
at this point you know I'm gonna see
this thing through no matter how many
people they have to kill off because of
contract negotiation have you heard of
Stockholm Syndrome
no what is that how I'm sitting here
with my captors the yeah the next season
AMC has announced that they are bringing
back Jon Bernthal somehow sure sure yeah
Punisher is Jon Bernthal is going to be
making an appearance even though the
character died twice I guess once as the
human wants this Walker keep
down him ask you something how am I
still alive he is coming back probably
it's some kind of loosen Ettore way or
some kind of dream sequence because we
also know that Andrew Lincoln Rick
Grimes and lauren cohan Maggie are
departing the show after 6 episodes but
they also announced just recently that
they're gonna be doing a time jump which
for those of you who read the comics
know that after the war with the
Savior's and negan they do a time jump
in the future so they're gonna be
working in both of those elements
somehow in this final season of the show
if you want to tune in just study wait
is the final season for sure oh it
should be is what he meant
yeah for those of you that still watch
Walking Dead
so you sir uh yeah
will you keep watching after Rick is
gone still deciding I think that's a lot
of us yeah you get another wristband we
shouldn't have made those a memory well
let us know your thoughts about this
update in the comments below but guys it
now comes the time for our new rosters
have sent us some questions that we have
but for those of you gathered around
will be going out to you if you have any
questions about anything that you want
to ask us so he's gonna be lightning
round questions could be prayer any of
the posts or someone sitting next to you
like do you like me or anything but yeah
you want to start us off right so I'll
start with one from home and I'll throw
this one to mod Dylan straggly wants to
know what mediocre power would you want
example never needing to cut your
fingernails I have so many mediocre
powers already I can tell this is
legitimate I can tell every time a guy
gets a haircut you know it's true
if you get it except once but every
other time meeting yeah that's all
that's my mile to the power P Mo's is
throwing wristbands in women's faces
like you don't even try to you say and
anybody any questions over here okay
since Maud asked for Star Wars
so recently they were talking about
pushing back the solo movies now because
of the reaction to solo the next movie
that they put out as a solo which
character do you think we have the
highest probability of success everyone
that would be one baby and why is it Jar
Jar by the way
okay so what's happened recently in the
Star Wars universe is that solo didn't
quite make nearly the kind of billions
of dollars that I thought it would so
they kind of reap had a little meeting
and they thought they would slow down a
lot of the production on the standalone
movies so we'd been promised above a fat
movie or a boba fett if you have an
accent I don't have one everyone else
does and then I also like a bunch of
other movies they're just slowing that
roll and focusing on the trilogy's which
makes sense because they're the ones
making the money because it's a clear
overarching storyline that everyone's
preparing I think that they shouldn't
have done solo first I think there was a
huge mistake I think focusing on an
origin story with the character
lightning-round that we shouldn't need
and that Harrison Ford still alive I
think we should have done everyone
because we could have had the original
actor playing it new McGregor wanted to
play it and it would tie together the
prequels but where we are now and there
were
yeah would've been great that's entirety
of our lightning round we got a couple
more question all right Sam at uh cam
got the juice wants to know ooh
in a movie about your life who would you
cast as yourself and what would the
title be huh Chris Pratt knock knock
Chris Pratt gotta be honest
either that kid from some Earl and the
dying girl you know that kid that kid
wait isn't he 13 reasons why not him
no a different kid I think I'll go I'll
do JT Justin Timberlake this one uh I
just want to see what he'll do with my
okay life what would he do with it
making it in my okay life the title that
movie you can kind of get my ears and
eyes and there's like okay a lightning
round got real Zapata wants to a Gabriel
stuff I don't want to know what film
deserved a sequel that never got one and
what sequel did not need to exist steel
spun what sequel didn't need to exist I
mean every single one that is like a
family like the Klumps
or The Cramps or like so all of those
things where it's like the family goes
to Christmas get rid of all the sequels
but I ever really easy answer for a
sequel we need to get is poor I'll call
it the name they wanted to call it for
live die repeat yeah yeah yeah movie is
like so good tomorrow yeah it's at your
tomorrow's original name all right Tom
Cruise likable I mean that's something
ya know and I need to see head to
tomorrow so I slipped I repeat again
times to again and again for Shrek 6
yes tracks love is like yep all right
and for me Hayden I born wants to know
would you rather be in a buddy cop movie
with Falcon or war machine definitely
Falcon because he seems like Anthony
Mackie seems hilarious I'd love to be in
a movie with that guy and drink of
choices what what do you think Anthony
Mac you stinking toys that are Falcons
can goes into the bar and orders a
really goes red red rip wing rip Brett
you got nothing bird Joker's sorry a
beaker lightning round
what is it Maude oh wow I thought I knew
you
okay well as always tweet us your ideas
for lightening around questions what you
want to know from us and you can be
featured in our videos and I'll try to
get your Twitter handle right but for
now let us move on back to our 15
seconds shout out so this is where we
get 15 seconds to shout out plug ramble
about anything we want to chat about
plug or ran to pull about Sam why don't
you start yeah check out I'll say check
out a podcast called all oh geez it's
about all different types of ologies
like dendrology psychology radiology and
this woman she this was she's a host
she's a comedian and she's so
intelligent and she makes all these
information so entertaining to learn
about if you like learning like
Scientology's downloaded wristbands I'm
shadow wristband that was Scientology's
not Scientology yeah or is that one of
those maybe later uh well first I'll
give one more shout out to filmora thank
you guys so much for everybody good just
download filmora we also are gonna do a
people been watching to this point of
the video we're gonna do a giveaway to
give you some free time with filmora all
you have to do is tweet this video share
it with a link to it and then add the
hashtag new rockstars filmora
to it that's how we'll find it so new
hashtag new rockstars filmora fil mor a
it's too much like my own name so I
almost felt my own name Phil Molina but
the thing I'll give a shout-out to is
guys look up reycarts while he's here at
VidCon he's speaking he's a futurist and
he's one of the most accurate futurists
that I've ever like existed and he's
doing the same thing I'm
trying to do he's trying to see if he
can actually seriously live forever so
he if you go see this guy he looks much
younger than he is he takes he used to
take 30 pills a day now he takes like
eight pills a day I think he's like
cutting it down to whatever yeah if
you're interested in pills this is you
guys a future check them out Ray
Kurzweil a find him around here and has
some questions about how to live forever
I'm starting a clothing line guys and
this is like I'm wearing the sweater
dress this is actually you can watch it
gold net is a sweater dress no duh
clothing line what what yeah what's it
called what is it called what Oh got it
third we have unlimited talent that it
is about everyone's got a full potential
and you can do amazing things you may as
well look really cool doing it it's a
geek Street inspired wear and it's for
guys and girls and it's got everything
from swimsuits to sweaters to hoodies to
joggers - pants - it's all happening and
we're launching in about two weeks so
yeah I'm doing a photo shoot this Sunday
and I'm going to supposed to be me in a
pool at the moment I could fill up the
pool with my snot
how can always be so attractive and yes
so also more attractive well how do
people find out about what what comm and
it's a shot what on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook to follow it
we've got some cool photo shoots and
pops up in one of them and I may or may
not be wearing a swimsuit for the first
time in public
my confidence is peaking I don't know
for my 50 tickets at out theirs I really
like the short film bowel that played
before a credible stew I was just like I
don't understand what is going on but I
loved it I thought it was really sweet
is really heartwarming and on YouTube I
found like they interviewed the animator
who had the idea behind it and how they
came up with the idea for it I thought
it was really sweet a very important
it's a go check it out to search bough
Pixar yeah you guys heard a Pixar that
Derek's shadow seven years and it's a
story about her own relationship with
her mother also fun fact when I watched
it I didn't know it was a mum I thought
it was a teenage boy oh you did - oh
just like eating snacks at the time this
is Louie why am i crying I cried during
that short did you guys cry during that
short cool oh my god
and I know your humor it's not like a
audience hype up thing let me hear you
cry it's time to find out both what's
going on with our trivia is your answer
to remind ourselves what the question
was we're looking for what was the super
villain for the Marvel Universe that
Tony Stark in these script furs Iron Man
was supposed to have designed the tech 4
but they took out the line because they
didn't have the rights to the super
villain literally with all of us
answered real quick before we read this
is a long one oh this is the contributor
question this is it all right so before
we read what our answers are Eric what's
our punishment if the person that gets
it the most wrong but we don't have any
in other news headlines to read this
week so what's gonna happen is because
we have this intimate setting here
you're gonna have to get intimate and
describe your most embarrassing moment
most embarrassing Peachy moment there's
kids around but you have to reveal some
some vulnerable part of your soul by
talking about the most cringy as most
embarrassing moment this can not be
included yeah if you can't tell if
you're at home watching there's an
audience of literally 250,000 people
yeah they all in unison made one sound
it sounded like one person but it's
250,000 people yeah there's more outside
of one to get in these are high-stakes
embarrassing stories yeah okay let's do
what we answered what did a Madre hi
she wrote doc dr. arc doctor on medical
don't dr. oz dr. dr.oz
okay Philip wrote doc doc
Eric roads Jocko and I drew an octopus
octopus so we always we always go to the
judges which by the way quick shout-out
to Devin is usually our judge Devon is
our editor give it over Devin everybody
[Applause]
this is one every promise later do they
start throwing the wristbands back at us
alright so we're gonna give it up to
everyone here we all answer Doc Ock but
you still have to bow who was the most
right and who was the most wrong so who
was the most correct is it Sam Aaron you
get all the wristbands
[Music]
[Applause]
alright Maude you're spared from telling
an embarrassing story
so it's essentially who do you want to
hear an embarrassing story from the most
Sam
Eric me Sam
I gotta go hard Sam easy volunteer to
throw on it
you can go to my channel youtube.com
slash sweet Munoz I have one
embarrassing story that I always tell
and I just can't tell it in this place
where I will be removed from the
building
[ __ ] knows it's tough I've really dug
deep and really uncovered a lot of stuff
that's usually embarrassing to normal
people but it my thresholds a lot
different now so off the top of my head
I sneeze into someone's mouth when I was
kissing them wasn't great how was your
nose in their mouth I wasn't I'm out yes
I'm wet I was drunk a party both drunken
and I thought I was going away I was
gonna go I was gonna kiss kiss and then
kiss kiss but it just kind of went
anyway and then weirdly she didn't keep
kissing me and that kept going or that
stopped I mean it didn't keep going I
went home after that did you cry no I
was drunk yeah I had no idea what
happened yeah it's like there I don't
remember
yeah I cry every time I'm drunk every
time you can't see cry yeah I have a
better one okay okay okay so I was at
work and I was walking around I was
wearing this pair of jeans but I liked
him a lot but I had a pair that had worn
out cuz his HT let me know they've
they're built to not last for a long
time so I was out out tonight and em
real quick over there I know so I was
walking around and I was like weird
they're like skinny jeans but like
they're fitting real good today and it
was like a different it was a different
pair and I was like that's super weird
and someone pointed out like a hole but
I was wearing one of those cool boy
t-shirts that like go all the way down
to like mid thigh they're like the
skinny cut whatever and I started
looking and like I felt like the hole in
the back of my thigh and then I like
kind of like followed it up and it
wasn't a whole it was a rip all the way
up my butt and like I was like I can't
this was after lunch so that means I
went outside and I was walking out in
the world with like basically my butt
out in at the mall I was at the mall and
I walked through H&M there and I had my
those same jeans on him my butt was out
at the mall and I just ripped it all the
way down trying to make jeans shorts
yeah did that win that girl back we'll
see okay well thank you all for joining
us thank you guys so much and thank you
all at home for watching nukes this is
also a special thank you to filmora for
hosting this these guys are great again
yes check out their website at Phil
Morecambe or Fillmore Warner sugar
yep easy film editing software remember
you're gonna get some free time with it
if you share this video and use the
hashtag new rockstars filmora yeah and
and also thank you to our hosts mr. Sam
basher Phillip Malina
Maude Garrett I'm Erik Bosse it's on
that's approaching down below tweet us
at new rock stars like share this video
around and subscribe direction few times
w love you see you next week and see you
guys around all this weekend by now get
your wrist bands